all right i'll give uh i'll give an
intro spiel and try not try not to
embarrass you too much
you know you are one of the the big dogs
in uh
in de la's studies yeah you know well
yeah we can talk about that i mean i
know people say that but if i'm a big
dog it's because when i started writing
i was interested into those and
uh i kept looking for someone who could
explain to lewis to me and there was
just so little out there and so i just
had to you know i feel like i have a
simple mind i had to write simply and
just lay it out for myself and you know
that's what the book was because i just
there wasn't anything out there when i
was starting so
but i guess then you become a big dog
but anyway
yeah yeah so
early adopter or you got that nose for
talent let me just quickly run this
intro and then we will get started
[Music]
hello listener you are on an overdose
episode of the plastic pills
podcast where we are back on deliz today
and with me is the voice of one who i'm
sure a lot of you are already familiar
at least in his uh textual format daniel
w smith so most de las anthologies that
you open up will have his name somewhere
in the table of contents
uh many edited the cambridge companion
to de las among others currently he is
the founder and co-director of the de
liz seminars project and you guys got to
check this out it's translating into
english like 20 years of seminars that
delivers gave at uh paris eight through
the 70s and 80s
and probably what's most important to
all you out there is that these seminars
were in large part
the the breeding ground of both
anti-oedipus and thousand plateaus so
dng did not just
pull these stacks of obscure references
from their own minds but they're more
part of a big collaborative effort
anyway we'll get to that
um with the man of the hour
daniel w smith
welcome to the pillpot
thanks pills it's great to be here
appreciate you having me on
and very excited to have you um we're
definitely going to get to the delusion
seminars project which will be the title
of the episode um
but i wanted to ask you first
dan because according to your cv
you've been you've been publishing on
delize since i was uh
playing cops and robbers in elementary
school and and i am older than most of
my audience
uh who seem to have this uh
thirst for the dillas
and guitari content
but i thought i should ask first
because you've also published on on
foucault and a few other french thinkers
but how did you come across
this persona and what about
de la's studies or deliz himself made
this uh your
philosophical home yeah that's a scary
question because now i'm like delu
recognized a little scholar which is
nothing i really had in mind uh when i
started writing on de luz because i was
just interested in delaware's and was
trying to figure him out back when i was
in grad school so i got into delaware's
in grad school actually started my
graduate career doing religious studies
and not philosophy and i was just
reading nietzsche on my own at that
point partly because of his critiques of
religion but also everything he was
doing philosophically and right about
then either delusion's translation the
english translation of delicious
nietzsche and philosophy came out or at
least i became aware of it and i read
that book and i was blown away just by
the reading of nietzsche that he gave
which was systematic and insightful and
pulled nietzsche together for me in a
way i didn't find in anyone else so i
remember going to the library at the
university i was at and luckily so it
was universe chicago and they had a a
good library and they had a ton of delos
books there none of you know whose
spines had been cracked at all but i
remember seeing difference in repetition
there and logic of sense and thinking i
need to i need to read more of this guy
and even though we were required to uh
you know pass french exams i decided i
really have to learn french now in order
to to read to lose so that's how i got
into them people often ask me what's the
best way to get into the lives and i
don't have a good answer to that but my
answer was uh what what i was reading at
the time is what got me into de so if
you're reading nature try the nietzsche
book if you're eating spinoza try
spinoza um
espinoza stuff
um and then uh i just had to decide on
what i wanted to write a dissertation on
and i thought well i'll write it on
dolores because at this point i'm
interested in reading de luz and there
was not much secondary material on him
so i falsely presumed that that would
make it a fairly easy dissertation to
write because i wouldn't have to wade
through a lot of secondary literature
and it turned out not to be quite so
straightforward because as you know
deluse is very
immersed in the history of philosophy so
i had to spend a lot of time you know
boning up on kant and bergson and
spinoza and nietzsche and everything
else the lewis writes on before i could
start to ride on him with any sort of uh
you know acumen so duller's wound up
being as i was writing my dissertation
wound up being my as dull as himself
says it was my apprenticeship to
philosophy
through through duluth
so early adopter and you said one of the
books you found in that library was uh
logic of sense was that your your buddy
charles's translation
no at that point uh the only books that
had been translated by de lewis were
anti-olympus
priest and signs and the masochism book
which i believe had early on been
published by grove press which was a
kind of not an underground press but
they had done
you know james joyce and people like
that who were deemed to be a little uh
risque and so i think there's a reason
why the masochism cut translated uh
early on antiochus which hugely popular
in france i think that's why it got
translated and then
the priest book was translated by
richard howard who was a poet so it's a
great translation but i think that uh
that got taken up in literary studies so
delis is a philosopher i think was
unknown for a long time some of his
books were these early books were
translated because they were i think
specific audiences that were interested
in them but i think delis as a whole
was still hidden you know for quite a
while until this at least in the
english-speaking world until the
translation started coming with more
force
all right if i could ask a follow-up
question so you
you broached this thinking it'd be easy
it turned out to be very difficult and i
think
probably for a lot of people that are
listening to this they've tried to crack
a book
anti-oedipus thousand plateaus been
overwhelmed
and got discouraged so
for those kind of people can you can you
tell them
what makes it worth
the effort and why is it worth it to get
to the end of that process
uh that's a good question i i mean i
think it's worth it because um
i do think for me if i write on dolores
and got interested in de loses because i
do think he's still
for me one of the great uh philosophers
of the 20th century i think he's one of
those indispensable philosophers and we
still have a lot of work to do on him
and if he's worth working through and
this is what i found myself as sort of
what i made my career on i didn't
understand duluth i was like everyone
else i read these books and i had a kind
of
how to put it to those makes a
distinction at one point between
effective readings of philosophers and
conceptual readings
so like spinoza is his example
it's written in a geometric style it's
not very accessible not something you
sit down and you know read while you're
trying to go to sleep or maybe you can
if you want to go to sleep quickly but
um
he says uh spinoza often affects people
before they really know what spinoza is
actually saying there's kind of an
effect he has on people that wants you
kind of provokes you to dig deeper and i
found that with de los i didn't know
what he was saying but it had an affect
on me that made it feel like i'm not
sure what's going on here but it seems
to me worth it to go deeper
and if you get that feeling with the
lows and it's not a bad feeling then i
think uh i would say it is worth it to
go deeper but it takes
it takes a little work and i don't think
there's any um
you know the downside is i think there's
no easy path getting into to lose i
think you just gotta
you gotta work at it um and the rewards
come they did for me and there's still
things i find very obscure into laws
and when i write papers i'm asked to
give talks that's where i have to sit
down and really do the grunt work and
try to put together for myself what i
think de luz is saying and that's what
becomes really
really fruitful so i do think he's worth
it but i i don't think there are any
easy shortcuts to trying to work through
him
there is a weird writing style he's very
academic he tried to dump the academic
style as he said an anti-oedipus but i
think that made it
uh even harder to read to be honest well
i think it's encouraging to know that uh
even after
decades with this stuff it's still
obscure i think that'll be a very
comforting thing to hear it is for me
um so getting to your book gondolas
which i don't know if you have uh
reviewed lately but you kind of divided
it into
three sections and this this talk is not
necessarily about your book but i
thought this would be a useful
uh rubric you talk about delis in the
history of philosophy
his commentaries and monographs
then de la is in his own system of
philosophy
and then third is de la's with concepts
so his the concepts that he developed
often
with qatari
and i was wondering
you you mentioned guitare a lot but
he's not the the subject of most of your
writings you usually focus on the de
la's half of those partnerships so
do you have a take on those co-authored
works as opposed to the monographs like
of course they they differ in form as
you mentioned and intent obviously
but were you drawn to one or the other
specifically
because you prefer the more
disciplinary philosophical approach in
the monographs or are they equivalent to
that's a good question and i'm going to
say something that will probably get me
in trouble with some people who read the
laws oh god we we like that that's drama
is good content yeah good uh you know
something scandalous so not that
scandalous but i've read you know almost
everything that qatari wrote um because
i'm interested into those but my
confession is that i just have never
been able to get into qatari himself the
same way i got uh and still get into
de los that's not a judgment on gotari i
think it says more about me i would say
the same thing about bergson who delos
loves and i've read almost everything
barrackson has written and it's not that
i don't appreciate and like bearson but
i just i just feel like i don't get into
him the same way like i really got into
nietzsche and kant and spinoza um and i
understand a lot of bergson but i i feel
like i don't know that effective
dimension is is missing
for me with barracks and it's the same
thing with uh guitare assuming i know
some people think de lewis gets um
or uh sort of
first billing over qatari sometimes and
certainly in my work um i'll just have
to confess it's because i find the law
is compelling um and it's not that i
don't find guitar compelling i know
dulu's got a lot from
um from guitar but personally i i just
find it harder to get into him like i
find it hard to get into um
into barracks and that being said your
general question of co authorship i
think is i've always found a really
interesting one because toulouse himself
i think needed he says at one point in
an interview he needed intercessors or
he needed mediators in order to do his
work and early on uh they were just
figures in the history of philosophy
it's almost like he couldn't think and
he says this he couldn't think on his
own he needed to write books on
nietzsche and then a book on spinoza and
then books on barracks and hume and they
were apprenticeships but he find it hard
found it hard to speak in his own name
he says and the first book he says he
wrote in his own name was difference in
repetition but even there when you read
it he's just like on every page
referring to all the philosophers he's
written on and many others besides it's
like he can't he can't help himself he
needs to think through other people but
i think that kind of came to a head in
may 68
um you know and even alain badu said he
was a kind of elitist thinker i don't
think that's true but i sort of see what
he's saying that he was very tied to the
history of philosophy and academic
philosophy
and
my own personal sense is that qatari got
him out of all that he still needed a
mediator you know intercessors but uh
guitare was and you know someone living
in the present
and someone connected to the president
he was working with lacan and uh into
psychoanalysis but he was also a
political activist and all those things
i think
the liz needed quattari to get him into
those domains because
you know he he was probably on the
spectrum as far as i can tell you know
he just worked that's what he did he was
just focused on his work all the time
and i i think at some point he realized
he needed someone like quitari to get
him out of i don't say his shell but to
get him connected to things that he
wasn't going to get connected to if he
just kept working
uh in the history of of philosophy but
it's a very curious question why
delusions and guitar needed each other
at a certain point and kept their
co-authorship
going for so long you know with
breaks in between
yeah i think the the interview you're
referring to is published in desert
islands
and the interviewer asked him something
to the effect of uh what's with guitar
taking second billing
and deliz said i i had hit a wall i mean
i'm paraphrasing i had hit a wall before
i even met him
and qatari is the one who came and broke
the wall for me but while we're doing
confessions um
i have a very painfully prosaic mind so
guitare solo works they don't do it for
me either
oh good well at least they're two of us
then i've just had lots of friends you
know who love guitarists i'm always
embarrassed
to say like as i say it's not a judgment
it's just a a confession about uh i
guess affectivity
now for all my for all my talking about
creativity i'm i'm not creative enough
to think through through uh chaosmosis
or whatever it is
um
so yeah uh this is the last of our of
our general
introduction get to know you questions
but
there's a lot going on in the world at
the moment
i'm not going to mention any specifics
or
tell you to answer what de luz what a
delusion has to say about this or that
but
why do you think in in a general sense
either
politically
generally speaking or institutionally
with the the university and and thinking
what is uh
what is a delizian perspective on uh the
world these days and why might it be
useful or valuable
well let me just start with the
institutional side because i do uh
um
you know delis says at some point uh
in france uh when so this is like more
about politics of just doing philosophy
as graduate students and as me a
philosophy teacher but there was a kind
of medical complex there because so much
of the training in french philosophy was
in the history of philosophy that's why
de lewis is tied to the history of
philosophy that's why derrida was tied
to the history of philosophy doing close
readings of the texts because they were
required to do that and i get the sense
in people like de luz and and derrida it
was like fine you want a history a
reading in the history of philosophy
i'll give you readings in the history of
philosophy because it was their
institutional context so they were
forced to do these close imminent
readings of texts so they had to find a
way to do that in a way
that they could be creative in a way and
produce their own philosophy in the
context of fulfilling these requirements
and i do think that's a um
an institutional situation everyone
finds themselves in uh doing philosophy
and not just philosophy if you're doing
law medicine you're deeply in an
institution that has its own norms that
you have to have to deal with so i think
there's a general question there of how
given the institution of philosophy and
now we have continental versus analytic
philosophy or just requirements for grad
courses or
uh you know the canon that you have to
deal with i think the big question is
how do you find a space
where you can think you know and be
creative as you say and think think the
new as delissa's philosophy is the
creation of concepts it's far easier to
say
uh than to do
i think and so that's one thing i get
from de los and i think frequently about
um
as a i guess i'm a professional
philosopher it's sort of weird to say
that but i get paid for doing philosophy
so i guess that makes me a professional
philosopher um but it's easy to get
caught up you know and all the
administrative stuff and the
institutional things that are going on
around one and and lose sight of you
know what we should be and
want to be doing as philosophers so
that's the institutional side with
regard to philosophy in terms of
politics and the the world at large um
not quite sure what to say there i do
think
um here here again this may be a more
limited response
but i do think delos and gotarian
capitalism and
schizophrenia produced a really
remarkable and remarkable new
uh
political philosophy and i think the
problem with capitalism and
schizophrenia as you pointed out early
earlier they're almost impossible to
read even for delusions you know it's
hard to know what's going on especially
in anti-oedipus so even people who work
maybe in political philosophy and might
be interested in seeing what de los and
gotari have to offer who have the best
of intentions are going to have a really
hard time reading those books and and
you know extracting what they
um
what they might be able to use so i have
to say one of my
little pet projects that i'm hoping to
do at some point is just to write a
short book on what exactly
that political
philosophy is which has to do with a
kind of typology or types of social
formations primitives states capitalism
and then in a thousand plateaus the
nomadic war machine because they are not
um stages in a kind of evolutionary
progression
that's what they're fighting against
that chapter and anti-oedipus that's
called primitives savages
and civilized people
is actually a riff from a book written
in the 19th century by and in lewis
morgan which was called ancient society
from primitives to barbarians to
civilized people it had a huge influence
on marx and engels and that's why de los
angeles but they never mentioned where
it comes from that title
but it's kind of a 19th century notion
of progress from primitives to
civilization and it's exactly what
they're trying to fight against
in
anti-oedipus because from their point of
view
evolution is not successive and time is
not successive it's not linear it's
really coexistence so they're they're
trying to do a political philosophy
where you see that you know territorial
societies over coding societies
capitalism as a decoding thing and then
nomadic war machines coexist
and that's the approach we should take
uh in uh in political philosophy
so that's not really an answer of how
it's applicable in you know any applied
sense but i do think there's a lot that
still needs to be done
um
on de los and guitars political
philosophy and making it accessible to
people who i think would be receptive to
it but who can't really
be bothered to try to work through
capitalism and schizophrenia on their
own
so that's just a plea to say i think the
political philosophy they've developed
is important you know they're people
like bad you and peter hallward who just
think he has no political philosophy
which is kind of weird because
capitalism schizophrenia is about a
thousand pages and it's nothing but a
political philosophy so uh
i don't know why people say that but i
do understand those books are hard to
hard to penetrate from the outside
they're not linear enough perhaps
as compared to the earlier monographs
yes yeah i agree with that wasn't it
jijic who said that ghatari was the
worst thing to ever happen to device
yes and there's a thesis there as well
because of course you jack is a kind of
likkanian slash hegelian
and um up until logic of sense like the
second half of logic of sense is the
laws essentially being a likanian
and trying to incorporate psychoanalysis
into his analyses and logic of sense and
then he meets guatari
and then anti-oedipus
is completely
its psychoanalytics analytic approach is
completely dependent on lacan on the one
hand so they're not really criticizing
him they admit their indebtedness but i
think they're really trying to invert
lacan
and because lacan is focused on the
symbolic and the real there's are really
these gaps or ruptures in the symbolic
and de los
angel in positive terms uh because
that's where schizophrenics dwell you
know they can't they can't articulate
things in the symbolic they're they
resist
uh psychoanalysis because uh they use
words as weapons rather than as
something that that has any meaning
but that's precisely the domain of the
real and they use you know
schizophrenia from a
clinical perspective but not just a
clinical perspective as a way of
thinking about the real so in that sense
i see them as trying to invert lacan
even though they're dependent on
lacan so yes guattari had a huge
influence on de lewis and i suspect
early on it was precisely
his work
with lacan guitars worked with lacan
that was appealing to the lotus because
he was at that moment where he
he was coming
coming to terms with psychoanalysis in
his own way
yeah this is one of the the binding
the binding chords between the two of
them one as a psychoanalyst one as a
philosopher
is
to contend with or offer an alternative
to
a representational logic or a world of
representation as opposed to the real
and together it seems like it's a matter
of political importance for them to to
suggest that politics is not changing
illusions it's changing reality yes
and before we leave the politics behind
i have a question for you specifically
because it's uh something that i've
really i think i've only heard or read
sorry heard read
you talk about it but that is the uh
ethics
because you've written on imminent
ethics and delays and
i'm the i'm the sort of person who kind
of recoils when i hear the word ethics
because i go well what i'm not
i'm not reading philosophy to find a
bunch of rules for life
and delis himself is of course not one
for
imposing moral codes by any stretch but
you um made the case i guess this was
several years ago
for an imminent imminent so
non-externally imposed
ethics derived from
the very the very ethically motivated
philosopher nietzsche
could you tell us what's at stake when
you formulate ethical questions
imminently instead of as like uh
codes or or rules imposed from from some
external vantage
and how then should we live yeah easy
question yeah exactly and i think that's
what i mean that's a good way of saying
what imminent ethics is although i think
delos develops in a way that
that question in a way that few others
have so internet ethics is not a
transcendent ethic so transcendence
would mean you have
sort of moral rules and norms that you
impose upon our behavior and you say do
this and don't do that and you try to
follow these transcendent norms de lois
doesn't like that because he's a critic
of transcendence but it really does
raise this big issue in ethics well then
what exactly is ethics and is it just a
free-for-all and relativistic which is
sort of how a lot of people go it's
objective or relative and that's exactly
not the path that de lewis goes he says
the opposite of
of transcendence is imminence but it has
its own uh cry criteria
so in imminent ethics we'll ask
um
about modes of existence and what is
is the nature of one's mode of existence
and it provides criteria so the two
great figures in the history of
inimitant ethics are spinoza and
nietzsche so nietzsche wrote a genealogy
of morals and in critiquing morals he
developed what nietzsche thought was a
kind of imminent ethics which had to do
with two types of mode of existence a
reactive type and an active type so just
to put in religious terms this is one of
the things that attracted me to
nietzsche early on he says we can't he's
like he's like we can't answer
metaphysical questions do we have a soul
is there a life after death is there a
god
but what we do have access to
are the modes of existence of people who
ask those questions or who need the
concept of god or the soul or an
afterlife and we can say what is it
about the nature of this mode of
existence that needs those concepts or
wants those concepts so what lies at the
heart of the genealogy of morals in
nietzsche is the concept he develops of
resulting or resentment like the reason
you would want to believe in another
world is because your mode of existence
in this life
is characterized by a resentment you
know against the world so that's what an
imminent mode of ethics is it's like
what's the mode of existence that needs
these concepts why why do you want to
pose these questions or seek for another
life and then spinoza i think
nietzsche got to eventually because i
think he gives even more concrete
criteria of how to think about a mode of
existence primarily with the two
concepts of affection and affect because
spinoza will say we're constantly
affected that's what an affection is by
things outside of us i'm affected by you
you know right now talking with you uh
people are being affected now listening
to this podcast but dullo says that
every affection will produce at the same
time an affect either of joy
or sadness so if you're liking this
podcast you might feel a little joy if
you think smith's an idiot and he's
saying nothing of interest then you you
know the opposite of that is sadness and
that'll be uh
sort of move down in your
you know your uh your affects so
it's a very concrete way of looking at a
mode of existence at every moment of our
existence we're being affected by an
infinity of things and everything that
we of which we have an affection
produces an effect so there's kind of
this constant up and down it's like a
melody
between joy and sadness and then the
criteria are how do we increase our joy
how do we avoid sadness sadness and um
and all of that are imminent criteria of
how to live your life
uh
properly and that's really at bottom i
think what an imminent ethics is is all
about
and it's tied of course one more thing
then you know it's tied to what we
generally think of ethics and politics
because
what affects you is also the political
organization you live within so when
spinoza defends democracy he says
because it's it's the type of social
organization that gives us the most
positive affects
so that's why affectivity becomes a
criteria for assessing what the best
mode of social organization is or could
be
so ethics rather than being
rules
is uh
more to do with expression could you say
or desire
yes desire that's delisa's contribution
to this um uh tradition in um in
anti-oedipus
um
and he gets that oddly from kant
because kant as you know wrote three
critiques and the first one had to do
with knowledge which was the faculty of
the understanding essentially the second
critique had to do with morality and
that's what
kant called the faculty of desire and
then the third critique had to do with
the faculty of pleasure and pain
but kant defines desire in a weird way
and i remember in grad school when i
read this i just did not understand what
kant was getting at because he says
desire
is a faculty that given a representation
in my mind i can produce the object that
corresponds to it and i read that and it
just seemed like magic like i think of
a glass of water i have a representation
of it and i can produce the glass of
water in front of me that's what it
sounded like
which of course is not what khan has in
mind because what he has in mind is i
think that i'm going to slap you in the
face and then i actually
affect that and slap you in the face so
desire is this faculty that can bring
about
things in the world it produces things
in the world
that's a real inversion of the usual
notion of desire where if i desire
something it's because there's something
out there i want and i don't have it
so that's the revolution de lewis
thought kant introduced into philosophy
desire is not something that indicates a
lack that i want something but i don't
have it and that's why i desire it says
desires this productive faculty where i
can think of something and then cause it
to happen in the world so dulles takes
that and puts it in the spinosast uh
nichian context and says yes desire is
uh
is productive
it is what produces our
social realities and our social uh
formations so it's a way of rethinking
kant without uh the moral law because
for con the will is simply desire raised
to a higher power where i'm subordinate
to the moral law so in an odd way de
la's uh in antiochus is trying to of all
people because he said kant was an enemy
of his and this is where he's an enemy
he's trying to take kant's theory of
desire and make it purely imminent in a
way that corresponds to uh spinoza and
uh
and nietzsche so that's part of what the
first
the first half of antiochus is about
kind of rethinking kant's notion of
desire along with psychoanalysis and
lacan inverting the con inverting
inverting kant and giving giving us a
kind of imminent notion of what desire
is and should be you're totally speaking
my language right now because i'm
the the the projects that i'm working on
internet based projects are
we have to
think of desire more as this connective
willing
and even in some cases
an unconscious willing or a willing that
can be manipulated rather than
you know i want something so i'm gonna
go get it because if we think of i want
something then we go get it then we
think of you know capital consumer
capitalism we think of it in the wrong
way we think of it only on the subject
side rather than as this you know a
productive
desiring machine
yeah exactly because that's their
argument they say it's really capitalism
or any social formation
it's that that introduces lack into our
desire
yeah but the re let me say one more
thing on this because i find it
important like there was this big
question when they were writing
antiochus on the relation between freud
and and marx because both of them said
that uh consciousness is determined by
unconscious forces on freud it was kind
of libidonal forces you know what we
think of as the unconscious in marx it
was class consciousness you know rich
people will think differently from poor
people you think in terms of your class
but the big question was how do you
unite
these two sort of unconscious economies
a libidinal economy that determines
consciousness and freud and a political
economy in marx
and the losing watari's thesis
um
is that those two economies are in fact
one in the same thing
in other words there's no sense in which
like we project our desires outward to
produce society and the society in turn
reflects back on us and we internalize
that
desire is part of the infrastructure in
a marxist sense which is simply a way of
saying like from day one the day you
were born your desires your instincts
like what you want to do
is social and political through and
through already
um and it's not something that you know
gets sublimated as freud said in order
to enter society desire is part of
politics from day one and your desires
are invested in the political system
that you
uh are born into from from day one so i
do think it's a really radical thesis
that's why i say i really think
anti-oedipus needs to be translated uh
you know conceptually into people to see
what's really at stake uh and what
they're doing in that book
i wasn't planning to ask you this
question but i i need to ask somebody
because i can't figure it out
um i think it's in it's in either
negotiations or desert islands but
they give this uh long critique of
libidinal economy and all that and it
sounds like they're having an argument
with marx and then at a certain point in
an interview they just say we have
always been marxists
period and this was i think already in
the 80s and i don't get it
i can't figure it out why are they
marxists
when they're introducing
so many uh various disparate elements
disagreeing with the marxists of their
time like uh altuzair
disagreeing with the critique of
ideology and then at the end of it they
say but we're still marxist
that's a great question and i thought
about that a lot because my take on that
is this on the one hand they say we are
and continue to be marxist because you
cannot do political philosophy
now without thinking about capitalism
and essentially marx you know wrote a
three-volume huge book called das
capital and he created that concept so
they're marxist in the sense that
they're working in the wake of marx and
working in the wake of capitalism and
its existence and you can't do political
philosophy without doing that and to do
that you're indebted to marx
the flip side is marx himself said that
capital by its very nature and
capitalism would change
and so de los angeles say so that
doesn't mean we simply take marx's
analyses and repeat them because that's
not what philosophy is philosophy is the
creation of concepts and you create
concepts in
uh in relation to changing circumstances
changing problems and one of the things
that is changing is capitalism
so they're marxist in the sense they're
interested in capitalism but they also
feel the need to create new concepts
to describe the current state of
capitalism there are more than a few
people from internet land that i hope
are hearing this
so it's true
that
for that reason then they will simply
let drop
and in a few instances critique
a lot of the concepts that marky marx
used to define or analyze capitalism
like ideology or infrastructure versus
superstructure or a contradiction you
know the idea that that's a 19th century
idea that history is you know hegelian
idea it's generated by contradictions in
this case between the proletariat you
know the capitalists and then that will
resolve itself and produce some new
stage in a dialectical uh history so
they say no you have to get rid of
contradiction as the motor of
history and introduce lines of flight
and all the the new concepts they
introduce
uh so that's how i see it their marxist
because they think you you can't do
political philosophy without thinking
about capitalism but they break with
marx because they think they you need
new concepts now in order to understand
what capitalism is doing um
leotard jean francois leotard did a
review of antiopes when it came out and
i think it's one of the best
reviews because that was exactly his
point since these guys say they're
marxist and yet he just goes through and
says and yet here are all these things
all these categories and concepts of
marks that they just either critique or
he says more than not they don't even
critique it they just ignore
these things and let them slide and
introduce their own concepts and i think
it's it's it's a good list of what they
what they take and what they let drop
from from marx's analysis
i'm very glad to have heard that because
that's been that's gonna that's been a
splinter in my mind for about a year
because they don't they don't even add a
qualifier it's just we always were and
we shall continue to be
marxists but okay there there's an
asterisk there though you know one
addendum to that i was in china well a
few years ago now and most philosophy
departments in china are in not many at
least are in the you know school of
marxist studies in any given university
um because it's china but i was talking
with us you know couple scholars who
remain unnamed who said actually in
china it's very difficult to talk about
marx which is which is somewhat
surprising but of course because there's
a kind of marxist ideology you know what
we call the party line and marx himself
is a rather
radical subversive figure and so even in
china talking about marx
is a difficult thing to do they were
saying uh because there's you know a
certain
way of talking about marks that's
acceptable and if you talk about you
know bring up other aspects of marx
you can get in
uh
serious trouble which is simply to say
there's the fecundity of marx i think
that has not disappeared it's
unfortunate marks marxism
you know we're in a post-marxist age
people say but uh he's so over laden
with everything that people think about
marx that actually going back to marx's
texts um happens
less often than it should so that's just
a plea for people to go back and read
marx himself
so you mentioned uh
talking to colleagues in china
this is
almost just a filler question before we
talk about the seminars project but what
what's about dilla's studies these days
what news is it
everybody madly
creating concepts is there drama uh we
had ian buchanan on here like two years
ago
and he got a little spicy with his take
that
anyone who does new materialism with de
las is uh completely missing the point
we can go back in and review that
episode but what's what's the landscape
for for the people
like me who are out of the game or have
never been in the game in the academic
side of this
you know i don't want to uh you know
wash my hands of this but i have to say
i'm not sure i know entirely i know
there's new materialism there's of
course object-oriented philosophy and
speculative realism with you know graham
harmon and um
there's accelerationism with nick land
there are a lot of if you like post
delosian
uh developments in in continental
philosophy all of which are sort of
related to the laws but also related to
daredevika you know everyone in that
classic generation
um
i'll have this confession like when i
was working on the laws
early on i
i i didn't understand everything and i i
was always looking for like secondary
works that would explain it all to me
and there were few if any
and there are some amazing deloitte
scholars out there but i still find
there's a huge bibliography but among
that bibliography the people are
actually taking the time to work through
de lewis carefully
and explicate his work so that other
people can understand i still find
rather small and so that's my
particular complaint and i think delos
himself
leads to this because he says the act of
philosophy is creating concepts and so i
think a lot of people rightly
take him seriously
and
and say well you know we're not going to
do the old school thing which is to do
close readings of de luz because duluth
intel itself teaches us even by his own
monographs yeah you're kind of reading
spinoza and nietzsche but you do so
you're doing so in order to create your
own concepts
um and so i think people tend to do that
with dolores they don't read him
carefully because they think the most
important thing is to create their own
own concepts and and
produce their own schizo flow as as
guitare might say
um
but the fact is de luz did the work you
know i mean he was exceptional it's hard
to for anyone to compare themselves with
the laws because he was a bit of a you
know prodigy even philosophically i read
once parenthetically in an early
interview where he said for him reading
philosophy was like reading a novel
and he could the concepts for him were
almost like characters and he would
follow the
the unfolding of a philosophical work
almost as if he was reading a novel and
there's these concepts and they would
interact with each other and there was a
story there and i believe him that he
just had that easy facility to kind of
you know when you read a novel you
imagine the characters and imagine the
landscape and i think the lewis did that
with concepts you can imagine the
concepts how they related to each other
what landscape they were producing
not many of us can read philosophy that
way maybe other people can but i
certainly can but i do my my complaint
is i
i think there should be more work where
people go back and do what i think they
uh believed
told us not to do which is do the
careful work of reading to lewis and
reading his philosophy and getting clear
on what he actually is saying because
one of the difficulties that i found so
going back to something you said early
on how i structured my book de los at
one point says he believes in philosophy
as a system and so i thought well great
i'll just try to lay out what deliza's
system is and the second part of my book
is called the lewis's philosophical
system and i i was trying to use rubrics
from
kant's system of philosophy
uh in order to see how you know de lewis
changed those rubric within those
rubrics he does something completely
different than kant but nonetheless use
those rubrics to see what his system is
so i use aesthetics dialectics analytics
ethics politics all the icks in
philosophy
and then i got frustrated because i
realized i can't i just stopped working
i can't pull together to lose a system
and just present it and it took me a
long time to realize why
and it's simply i mean it should have
been obvious that de la says philosophy
is the creation of concepts but what it
means is that de lisa's concepts are
changing even within his own work you
know they do not remain
the same and so there's no system i can
present because and he self says this
every book he did was a new project
he wrote
difference in repetition and he has a
notion of intensity there that he says
is related to the concept of depth but
then he wrote logic of sense and retains
the notion of intensity but now it's
related to the notion of surface
and then he wrote anti-oedipus and he
says i still have the notion of
intensity but now it's not related to
either depth or surface
but it's what takes place on a body
without organs
and then at the end of his career he
writes what his philosophy and intensity
reappears but now it's a word he uses to
describe the components of concepts
they're intensive and not extensive so
that's just one example even within
deluse's own work and this is himself
pointing to the becoming of concept they
change all the time so
that's what he means by saying
philosophy is a system it's a it's a
heterogeneic system in other words it's
constantly generating the heterogeneous
so i finally realized that yes it's a
system but it's not a system you can
ever like lay out and say here's the
final form because of course there is no
final form and that's why i think people
want to take up to lose his own concepts
and create their own concepts because in
a way that's that's they're extending
what deluse uh himself did
but um yeah that was an early
frustration i i had this idea i could
present the system but i had
a false idea of what that system might
be or how you could present it
well it's a system but not a systematic
system well as duluth says it's a new
concept of what a system is you know but
this i wanted to point this out because
if you are are out there and you've
tried to pick up adele's book a few
times and put it down and or if you pick
up even books that he wrote like
consecutively
you can't
map the same body without organs between
two books uh the definition of the
virtual changes at least
three times between uh
a thousand plateaus and the cinema books
and then it has a completely different
well not completely different but
seemingly different
definition when he gets to
leibniz in the 90s
so if you're frustrated by it
i think even delis and gatari said we
don't even know what each other means
when we say body without organs so
yes i remember reading that and i
thought thank you guys because if you
guys can't you figure it out what are
the rest of us supposed to do
yeah
all right so um
we are here
listener if you've been interested so
far
i'm here to
reintroduce you
to
a resource that you have to check out
because it's been um
two years since
your buddy
charles staval
was on the podcast uh he gave us a bit
of a summary of what is called the de
las
seminars or no seminars or seminar
the duluth seminar is plural the delize
seminars project it is a website and as
i kind of mentioned at the beginning
it is you could spend a thou this
project is huge
you could spend a thousand hours on here
and i've spent
10 hours on here
there are pdfs there is plain text there
are videos and all of it is one spot
all of it is de los angetari
um
spans 20 years it starts when deliz i
don't even think he was graduated yet
you have something from like
the late 50s on there i think too we
have some very early stuff yes
anyway instead of me introducing it i
will let you introduce it can you tell
us what the project is and why us uh
anglophones
should be excited about it and uh how
far are we into it because i as i said
there's already a thousand hours of of
reading on there and how much further do
you have to go
yeah well thanks i appreciate you
bringing this up because yeah it's a
very exciting project uh for me
um
so in a way the project is delusion's
knock losses they say it's his you know
the stuff he didn't publish you know
nietzsche took uh wrote stuff in
notebooks and slowly but surely those
notebooks could be were published and
you could see sort of nietzsche's
thought in process and
heidegger for instance gave courses and
he wrote out all those courses and other
volumes and volumes that have been
published of heidegger stuff uh delos
didn't do that he didn't keep notebooks
uh he didn't
write out his
lectures
uh he gave a weekly seminar at the
university of paris first at the vance
campus and then at centenni and
apparently from what i've heard he would
at best come with a little sheet of
paper with a few notes of kind of the
what he wanted to talk talk about that
that day in a kind of conceptual
deduction
but that's how i see the importance of
this project at the duluth seminars
because that weekly seminar was really
his laboratory his thinking laboratory
where he worked out his ideas that
eventually became published in in book
form
and so our pro
our project has been to produce english
translations of those um uh seminars
the
project began at the university of paris
eight where de lewis taught shortly
after his death
partly because there was one student
interestingly a japanese student
hidenko suzuki was his name who from
1979 until
1987 or 85 whenever delaware's retired
he went to every seminar
sat next to delos and recorded the
seminars
and it's there were lots of people who
are recording the seminars we've kind of
launched a data rescue to see if we can
get tapes that we don't have from suzuki
to kind of flesh out the archive
but he gave his tapes to the bibliotec
nacional the national library of france
they archive them turn them into mp3s
and they're now all available
through the national library there's an
archive of delos's recordings
uh shortly after his death a committee
was formed headed by alain badu believe
it or not to
[Music]
transcribe all those recordings just
transcribe them into french
and put them on a website at the
university of paris eight which is there
and that took i believe 15 years
to finish all those transcriptions
because there are so many of them and i
believe they just got graduate students
at the university to help them over the
years and do this i got involved in this
project because
they had not transcribed the foucault
seminars and i really wanted to read
those and so i offered and got a grant
from my own university hired someone to
uh and annabelle de fork who's a really
good scholar on her own but um back then
she transcribed the foucault lectures
because i wanted to read them myself and
then we gave them to parasite and they
put them on their their website and then
they finally finished the transcription
so what we're doing now is simply trying
to translate all of those uh
seminars seminar lectures and make them
available in english because obviously
more people speak english than french
and it makes it available to a much
wider audience
the importance of them here's the story
i tell about the importance
there was early on a and it still exists
a web page called web page called web
deluge that had been started by richard
pinhaus who's a musician but also was
one of delos's students and a friend of
the de lewis family and he had done some
recordings and he put some of them
online early on and one of the ones he
put up
was a
livenet seminar
that he called the tavern
like the bar
which is a question leibniz poses at
some point about human freedom
saying how do you decide when you're at
home working and writing an article for
instance or doing philosophy but you
think maybe i'm going to go out and now
take a break and have a drink with my
friends it's just a question of decision
theory what goes on in making a decision
do i stay at home or do i go out and
have a drink with my friends and they're
only about two or three or three places
the lewis says in leibniz where he talks
about human freedom because most of the
time he's talking about the freedom of
god you know god thinks possible worlds
and all that stuff and then decides to
create this the best the best of all
possible worlds so here's about a three
hour seminar on this question just what
is a decision for humans how do we go
about making a decision which i thought
was fantastic it has to do with micro
motivations and the unconscious
differential notion of the unconscious
that leibniz develops that i had seen
nowhere else in dallas and i was
completely
fascinated but also flabbergasted why
this what i thought a profound analysis
appears nowhere in delos's work so i
went and looked at the live nets book
and sure enough the
the topic is there but everything that
took place in this three-hour lecture
which you know in transcription is about
30 single space pages is reduced to
three lines
in a single paragraph or maybe a single
paragraph maybe five lines and i myself
could never read the leibniz book and
reproduce what goes on in the seminar
but i can see having read the seminar
uh what went into you know that
paragraph so for me personally as a
delos scholar i began to realize that
the seminars he
was giving were really as i say his
laboratory where he was working out a
lot of his ideas
and you can see it when you start
reading the seminars for instance the
the cinema books that de la is published
in 1983 and 1985
were the result of a four-year seminar
that he is giving a three hour lecture
on every week
and so just for those two two books
alone and this is what we're in the
process of translating and finishing now
there's pages and pages and pages of
reflections on the nature of time the
nature of movement sometimes he'll he'll
say today i'm just going to do
philosophy and then other
sessions will say today we're going to
do film
and there's material there that just
just didn't make it into the books so
it's a vast you know resource and as i
say the peril there's parallels between
nietzsche and heidegger and lots of
other people they're
they're the background material that
kind of show the inner workings of
delos's thought that you simply
don't get could never get in the
published material and uh for me it's
it's i think hugely important and i
think charlie and i charlie staval who
has
uh now become the co-director of the
project i think we see it as a work uh
for posterity because there's so as you
say there's so much material there and i
think this will make it available to
you know subsequent scholars who are
trying to work under those and try to
think and see how he thought what he was
thinking this i think will be an
incredible and valuable resource for
them
so normally yeah you go to a seminar
in like grad school or even
upper level undergrad and the seminar
takes the form of the
course director professor
kind of summarizing and and simplifying
their own
past work
and maybe you'll read one of their
chapters and discuss it like this and
this is completely the flip side this is
the opposite of that if you read the
published work you're gonna miss
like the other thousand pages that he
wrote on exactly
the topic so the
the books are abridged versions of the
lectures as opposed to
the other way around at least that was
my impression
no that's true yep and i have to say
it's a very french thing and they're you
know the flip side is their i don't say
problems with that that's what uh
foucault did his uh um lectures at the
college de france have now been
published
and um you know in france you're when
you become a famous professor
you know you're kind of an oracle people
come and listen to what you have to say
because you're developing your books
while you're giving these uh lectures
when i was at in grad school another
french philosopher paul recur who was a
hermeneutic philosopher would come to
the university of chicago where i was
just for 10 weeks we were on the quarter
system so each quarter was 10 a week so
he would come and i would take all his
classes but he was doing the same thing
he made them exciting classes to take
but he was just developing the books he
was working at the time in the context
of the courses he was giving the book he
was doing a book called time and and
narrative
that being said like recur i remember
hearing him say he wanted to come to the
u.s to try to get away
from this uracular
status you know that french professor's
hat and you can see de los trying to do
the same in his own way
when you read the the transcripts of the
seminars he's giving he's constantly
trying to say i'd like you to ask
questions you know i'd like you to
interact with me i'd like to hear what
you have to say um
but i think the here again this going
back to what i say about institutional
structures and philosophy i think the
structure in france was so set up that
you know professors have this
kind of elevated status that um
it's it's kind of rare i don't say it's
rare it happens quite frequently
but there are certain number of people
who take delaws up on that and are
frequently asking questions it's almost
always the same people who take that
invitation to um
you know to talk a lot
so
look you dorks
i'm stressing this
you know i don't run ads and dan is not
paying me to say this
but you have the links in the
description and you need to click on it
so
you gave this uh the the leibniz
anecdote that this these pages are
reduced to lines if you are a budding de
luz scholar
and you need a dissertation topic or
you're
you don't think that there's anything
left to study
you're wrong because if you go through
this website you might be one of the
first people to stumble across something
there so all you out there you know eric
buddy from the podcast pillpod
um he's studying charles sanders purse
and he got pissed off because dillas did
like
a handful of references to cs purse in
the cinema books and that's it never
elaborated but eric went to this site
completely independent of me doing this
interview
and found full ass lectures on
purse which he was extremely excited
about so there'd be gold in them hills
and you will thank me for it and i'm
thanking you for that plug
and i will say too uh they're they're
much more accessible than delos's books
because he he doesn't write out his
lectures so
all of these he's speaking
extemporaneously and for that reason
they're very accessible i have to say
it's kind of like lacan you know lacan's
writings are very difficult uh but the
seminars are much more accessible and uh
the same is true of de luz so uh if you
wonder where to start indulos i'm not
sure it's a place to start but it's
certainly where you'll find clarity
uh they're clearer than deluse's books i
would say
so are there are there any things you
found recently maybe
uh
specific
paths of concepts you could say or maybe
just about diluz's personality himself
that have really changed since uh
doing the the seminars project and
seeing how he worked through this
or is he just an uh an otherworldly
savant that none of us have a hope of of
reaching
that's an interesting question because
recently uh charlie and i have talked
about this
um de los started his seminar books
clearly with the idea that he was going
to use bergson and that's obvious when
you read the books as a as a kind of i
don't want to
say template but as a kind of using
bergson's philosophy to understand and
read through cinema and using cinema to
understand a barracks and because
bergson was interested in movement
and then in time and the two volumes are
you know the time the movement image and
the time image and that's taken directly
from bergson by the time you get to the
fourth year of the seminar
uh it's not that barrickson has
disappeared but he you know obviously
he's a creative thinker and he's moving
in a different direction and the
direction he seems to be moving at
toward is what his philosophy
because the last chapters in the time
image are about cinema and thought
and philosophy and he's starting to talk
about philosophy as the creation of
concepts
filmmakers create images
artists you know painters create images
using line and color so he's very much
heading toward
what eventually is going to be published
in in what is philosophy and you can you
can see that development there
um
in what is philosophy he talks about
what science does as functions not the
creation of concepts but the creation of
functions
but in the cinema lectures he's not yet
using the word function
he's seeing science as the creation of
operations or operators
in french so he's clearly like looking
for a language and eventually when he
publishes what his philosophy he settles
on the idea that science produces
functions but he's not yet there he's
saying science produces operators
or operations so you can see that that
history and then the puzzle is
um
why he doesn't immediately start writing
what is philosophy and one obvious
answer is foucault dies
and so after he finishes the cinema
books
he spends a year doing a seminar on
foucault partly an homage to his friend
but also i think to really come to terms
with foucault's work now that he's dead
and there's a body of work uh to deal
with
but there again instead of going on to
what his philosophy afterward and this
is the mystery to me he decides to do a
year-long seminar on spinoza he's
already written lots on spinoza in the
past clearly no spinoza well
but decides for reasons that aren't
entirely clear to me
they're clear when you look at the end
of the foucault book because he starts
thinking
uh about foucault in fairly light nitsy
and terms so he felt like i don't know
what he needed to go back to leibniz um
and i heard a story
when i was in france as a student from
someone who had been sitting in deliza's
seminars but you really saw a mountain
about town but he was in one of the big
bookstores in in paris in the left bank
and he heard to lose his voice which he
was used to because he went to the
seminars
and he looked over and delos was buying
books and he had two piles of books one
were primary texts of five minutes the
other was secondary text and essentially
he had cleaned out
all the the leibniz books that this
bookstore had to offer and his
interpretation was de los always said
when he did a project he would start
from scratch for some reason he decided
he wanted to go back to leibniz uh but
he wasn't going to do what you said sort
of repeat his
previous work he wanted to start from
scratch re-read leibniz uh you know from
scratch and and rethink uh leibniz so
i'm not sure why he did that that's one
of the puzzles for me why that leibniz
um book is in the trajectory of duluth
when at the end of the cinema works he's
he's heading toward what is philosophy
but that's the kind of material that's
why your question is a good one you you
in reading the seminars you you can see
de lewis working things out and heading
in a certain direction and yet taking
detours or running into blocks and
roadblocks where he starts developing a
concept like early on he
developed a concept of the audio visual
which was coming from gotari i believe
and yet it wound up not getting put in
anti-oedipus you know it was a concept
there but just for some reason got
blocked and not developed all those are
things
uh you can see when you read the
seminars if you're attentive you know of
um
i don't want to say like the books are a
final word you know that everything is
set and de lewis you know knows exactly
what he thinks there but in the seminars
things are much more fluid and tentative
and you can see his mind at work in a
really
i think fascinating and revealing way
all right i got one
last drop in question that just came to
mind and it's another one of those i've
been wondering a long time and now i
have you here and then i and then a
final question so
compared to uh i mean
gotari's name is on
what is philosophy
but compared to
uh
kafka compared to
a thousand plateaus and compared to
anti-oedipus
it's much more difficult at least for me
i don't see his voice in there
was there a different co-authorship
arrangement or
am i missing it
i don't know definitively the answer to
that question um
but i share your suspicion and i think a
lot of people do
that delus mainly wrote what is
philosophy it has that kind of
well flavor delusion yeah
not the flamboyance that you would get
from
gwatari you know gotari's notebooks have
been published while they were working
on anti-oedipus and
uh there's one point where he's he's
kind of resentful towards de lewis
because he says de luz all he cares
about is the project he's writing and
working all the time and he says me i
just want to produce like the schizo
flow
and it's true when you look at the text
that guitare was feeding to de lewis
that the laws would then revise
into anti-oedipus
they are indeed kind of schizo flows and
and uh
and that being said i'm not even sure
like the idea that philosophy is the
creation of concepts i think that is the
laws as well i'm not sure guitare would
have thought of philosophy that way i'm
sure he thought of himself necessarily
as a philosopher but if he did he was
more interested in writing diagrams like
diagrammatization right diagrammatism
which is a concept they develop i think
that's much more how gratari worked
rather than producing concepts
so yes i think what his philosophy is
very much of the lowe's book but at the
same time i think he was aware that
a lot that he was developing in that
book came out of his work with with
gwetari
and so uh he didn't want to you know
claimed that it was a delos book so
that's my suspicion but uh you know
qatari was still alive and they were
working together so i don't really know
what the working relationship was
at the end there for for what is
philosophy but i share your your sense
that the text reads much in a much more
delosian fashion than a quitarian
fashion
well that's another another little
splinter taken out of my mind so
at least at least i'm not alone um so
final question is about the delis
seminars site we've hyped it here and if
uh someone wants to go there
i mean it's overwhelming there is a
search function and the search function
actually works pretty well like if you
uh today i typed in
a diagram
because i was looking up something for
something else and uh it brought me
straight to lectures that all include
the word diagram but how if you if
someone's hearing this and they're like
i want to do this and then they go there
and they're like holy [ __ ] this is
900
pages of of stuff how what's the best
way to negotiate or look around should
they come to it with a topic in mind if
they're already interested
in it but how do you deal with all this
without being overwhelmed
you know that's a very interesting
question and i actually would like to
hear
from any of your listeners or from you
even
have suggestions on that score because
you're right it's a huge uh it's a huge
amount of material there and our focus
now is so if we got some ui designers
leave in the comments and you'll get
cited in the project yeah you will and
your suggestions and if you find
you know this is like even if you find
typos or errors because usually you find
an error you know you're not really
concerned about that because you're
interested in the content but we're
concerned about that because we really
want this to uh you know be a good site
so do not hesitate there's an email
address there for the site to email us
and let us know but your question is a
good one uh and we don't yet have a
definitive answer there is a setup that
we're working on uh
you know in each page at the beginning
of the seminar there's ideas referenced
and people referenced and
the long-term project is to build a
critical editorial apparatus around the
seminars so you could click on say a
concept like body without organs
the search engine will bring up any
uh seminar in which that is referenced
but then we would like to write short
articles that are
kind of helping people
you know go to the right places
in the seminars that would be most
relevant to their their interests
um
but we're working on how how to think
through that how to build an editorial
apparatus that will allow people to
to use the site and you know because
people like me i've read most of them
because i'm a dolo scholar not
everyone's a delos scholar that's going
to have the time to read through all
these seminars so we want to find a way
to allow people to get into whatever
topic they're working on particularly if
you're not a philosopher and you're
interested in say
we've just finished the paint delicious
painting seminars which is the seminars
he gave while he was writing the francis
his book on the painter francis bacon
you know so if you're a painter or an
artist and you'd like to get more
information on how delos thought about
painting we want to think of ways that
people can you know get to the topics
they're interested in quickly without
getting overwhelmed with the amount of
material so we have some ideas on how to
do that but i would welcome uh you know
advice suggestions from
users of the site and how how that might
be done and
any comments or suggestions that people
might have on that score
yeah it's kind of rhizomatic because if
you if you go to i have one open right
now so if you go to a page
then on the side there's a whole bunch
of links of every single
topic
uh like a hashtag reference of
aesthetics catastrophe the sublime you
click on that and it'll bring you to all
the other ones that have that referenced
and same thing with people so there's
artists referenced obviously
philosophers referenced
and it it becomes a good way to kill
some time if you are uh
if you are just bored on a saturday
spend it spend it rhizoming through
delizes
yeah if you click on the names i've just
started trying to uh you know give some
short biographies on some people so
we're just just just starting down this
path
um
that's a much broader project to to
write that editorial apparatus
but um
but yeah that's that's that's future
work
um but you're pointing to a problem in
in the sense not a problem but a sense
that when there's so much material
and it's not going to be published so
when dillo's died
he left one of the stipulations in his
will was no posthumous publication his
wife fannie interpret that to me no
print publication she's in a way like
old school because she didn't see
internet as a publication
so she allowed uh richard pinhaus to put
stuff on webb de los and she allowed
paris aide to transcribe all these
seminars and she gave her blessing to
our project to translate these into
english
free of charge
but she was fairly adamant that there
would be no print publication maybe not
bad these days because most people
students certainly these days are more
comfortable going online to find their
stuff but it's it's still easier in a
way to find your way around a book you
know if we could publish these in book
form
one of the things we're hoping to do in
the future is maybe to get um
you know ebooks uh kind of pdf books or
something like that where the once an
entire seminar is translated and
corrected and we feel satisfied with its
final result
um to just put it in an ebook
and so that can be downloaded um because
it takes a bit of work to jump from
seminar to seminar
and this is just mad i'm looking at i'm
looking at the uh
painting and the question of concepts
and then the people reference they're
half artists like francis bacon oh he's
probably writing the francis bacon book
at this point it makes sense but paul
cleese in there rembrandt kandinsky
and then gotha all of a sudden well it's
just
this seems like a good way to read
once it's uh
oh sorry last question last question for
sure how far is it from being finished
do you think
well translation-wise we have finished
everything except the last two years
of the cinema uh seminar so
we're working on those that being said
those two years you know there's like 25
or 26 three-hour lectures in each of
those so add up the total hours you know
it's three or seventy-five probably 150
hours of material so it's still quite a
bit that we have to um
to work through i will make this plea as
well to people who might be listening um
as i said the most of the archive is
based on the recordings of the this
japanese
student hidenko suzuki who recorded most
of them but we know there are a lot of
other people
recording things prior to 1979 when
suzuki started attending so if anyone
out there knows of course they'd be
fairly old now people who attended the
seminars especially in france but if you
know people who might have recordings we
really would like to you know uh flesh
out the archive
from the seminars that occurred before
1979 we found quite a few
but um you know if you know of anything
get in contact with with us before those
cassettes start disintegrating or the
people who own them start uh
you know
kicking it yeah
well you've promised a few people jobs i
don't know if you've if you're aware of
this but you said we need some people to
just be de la scholars only explicating
so there's some jobs for you
you can you can talk to dan he'll put in
a good word for you at purdue
uh we need ui designers with their ideas
and we need anyone who's got
grandparents who are kicking it in paris
in in the 70s and 80s or no me parents
probably yeah probably parents it could
be green yeah so yeah lots of jobs out
there many opportunities
well thank you so much for coming on dan
this was uh
enlightening exciting excellent uh
everyone who is listening
you got you got to look at this site
and they're asking for help so
i know that you always just love me
giving uh feedback that i didn't ask for
this is feedback that's being asked for
so uh dan do you got any uh parting
words for the
i don't know 6 000 or so people that are
going to listen to this well i don't
know if you're listening to this you
probably like philosophy and philosophy
is not a
it's not a normal thing to do in this
world but uh it's one of the best things
to do in this world so i would just uh
tell people to keep at it keep listening
to pills podcasts and and thinking about
things and
and reading the books because
yeah we don't talk about much of
contemporary politics but you know
people say we're in a post-truth age and
you know people use language and
concepts and
not always the best way so
um keep doing philosophy that's what
i'll say
all right thank you so much and uh we'll
end it there thank you pills thanks for
having me on it had a lot of fun
recording stopped
[Music]
you